In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for August 25, on which we commemorate, the Holy Apostle
Titus, Bishop of Gordina, in Crete.
Of pagan origin, the Holy Apostle Titus was converted by St. Paul, who called him,
my own Son, after the common faith.
Many years later, in about the year 49, they met again in Antioch, and Paul took him with
Barnabas to Jerusalem, to report to the Apostles on his mission to the pagans.
Convinced by Paul's arguments on exemption from the precepts of the law, the members of
this first council did not demand that Titus be circumcised.
In that time on, he followed the Apostle in his missions, and became one of his closest
fellow-workers.
It was he, who was sent to Corinth to take them the Apostles' first letter, and to explain
how to take a collection for the faithful in Jerusalem.
But after Titus had left the town to go and tell Paul the results of his mission, serious
troubles divided the Christians of Corinth, and Paul, who was in Ephesus, in about the
year AD-55, sent Titus a letter, written with many tears and anguish of heart, in order to
set right irregularities.
He was received with fear and trembling as the bearer of apostolic authority, and after
having restored good order and charity, he rejoined his master in Macedonia to report
to him with joy on the obedience shown by the Corinthians.
Paul then sent him once again to that town with two other companions, with the mission
of taking the Corinthians his second letter and receiving the fruits of their collection.
Even once again with St. Paul in Rome, at the time of the Apostles' first imprisonment,
Titus accompanied him when he went back east, landing on the island of Crete, they evangelized
a number of towns together, and Paul, who had to continue on his way, left Titus there,
to complete the organization of the new church, placing bishops in each town.
When he encountered strong opposition, especially on the part of the Jews, Titus wrote to Paul,
who in reply encouraged him to reach all that was in conformity with Holy doctrine.
who in reply encouraged him to teach all that was in conformity with holy doctrine, in
all things showing himself a pattern of good works.
Warned by this misive to be ready to join Paul in Nicopolis, it was thence that Titus
was sent on a further mission to Dalmatia.
After St. Paul's martyrdom he returned to Crete, which he governed with wisdom and pastoral
zeal, to great old age.
He fell asleep in peace, and his body was placed in the cathedral at Gortina, his episcopal
seat, where he was venerated for many centuries as the protector of the Church of Crete.
When the island was liberated from its Arab occupiers, the capital was transferred to Kandake,
and a new cathedral was built in honor of the Holy Apostle Titus.
This church remained the principal pilgrimage center on Crete during the Venetian occupation
in the years 1210 through 1669.
Driven from the island by the Turks in the year 1669, the Venetians took the skull of St.
Titus with them and placed it in St. Mark's Basilica.
This precious relic was returned to the Church of Crete on the 12th of May in the year 1966.
According to another ecclesiastical tradition, St. Titus was a distant descendant of Menos,
King of Crete, and showed from childhood a lively attraction for the pagan sciences.
When he reached the age of 20, he heard a heavenly voice saying to him, Titus, you must
leave this place to go to Jerusalem and find the salvation of your soul.
For profane knowledge will bring it nothing of any use.
Fearing however that this voice might have come from the demons to cast him into delusion,
he continued his pagan studies.
After nine years he had a further vision during which he received the command to read the
Jewish scriptures.
He therefore opened the book of Isaiah and his eye fell on these words.
Ye aisles make me a feast.
Israel shall be saved in the Lord with an everlasting salvation.
The Pro-Consul and Governor of Crete, who was also Titus' uncle, having heard tales
of the miracles worked by Jesus in Jerusalem and throughout Palestine, decided together with
eminent men of the island to send his nephew there to gain fuller information.
Arriving in Jerusalem, Titus saw the Lord and the miracles he worked and witnessed his life-giving
compassion, resurrection, and ascension.
He was even, it is said, numbered among the disciples who received the Holy Spirit on
the day of Pentecost, ordained priest by the apostles.
He was then sent on a mission with St. Paul.
They went to Antioch together and then to the region of Salusia and then to Cyprus.
From Salamina they went to Perga in Pamphilia, Pesidian Antioch, and Iconium, and then preached
in Lystra and Durb, enduring persecution and ill-treatment in all these places.
When they arrived on Crete, they were received by Restylus, the Governor, Titus' brother-in-law.
He tried to persuade them not to preach against the pagan gods, but without success.
Shortly afterwards, St. Paul, by his prayers, revived the Magistrates' son, who had just died.
From that time, Restylus showed honor and respect to the missionaries, giving them full leave
to spread the good news throughout the island.
But after three months, he was called to Rome to become consul there.
The Jews then began to harass the infant Christian community by their vain discourses and
lies, without, however, daring to lay any blame on the apostles who were protected by such
a high-ranking person, leaving the island of Crete to go to Ephesus, where many pagans
were being converted, Paul sent Titus, Timothy, and Erastus to Corinth.
After having helped the apostle till his death, Titus worked on the confirmation of the
mission in Greece and Colossus, before going back to his own country to continue its evangelization.
He was received with delight by the inhabitants, but it was soon clear to him that they had
kept their pagan practices.
The apostle then went up to the statue of Artemis, and threw it down to the ground in the name
of Christ.
More than 500 pagans were converted on seeing this miracle, and cried out,
great is the God preached by Titus.
Installing his episcopal C in Gortina, St. Titus established nine bishops for the principal
towns of Crete, and confirmed the true faith by both words and miracles.
At the age of 94, the holy apostle was nearing death.
His house was suddenly filled with a fragrant cloud, and a host of angels appeared to help
him.
His face, as radiant as the sun, he gave his soul into God's hands, saying these words.
Lord, I have kept the faith and have confirmed thy people in the fear of thee.
Receive now my spirit.
When they took his white clad body for burial, the pagan temples were cast down, and many
of the possessed were freed at his tomb.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ, our God, have mercy on us
and save us.